bon forme fameux lundi 21 septembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de notre actualité
retour sur la mobilisation nationale des
élus contre la diminution des dotations
accordées par l'état nous étions à
poissy samedi où se trouvait députés
sénateurs et maires tous craignent pour
l'avenir des communes en plateau avec
nous jean michel fourgous mer les
républicains bel en cours et premier
vice président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines journée
mondiale autour de la maladie
d'alzheimer c'est aujourd'hui en france
850 mille neuf cent mille personnes
seraient touchées nous en parlerons avec
jacqueline huet responsable de france
alzheimer saint quentin en yvelines et
enfin le bilan des journées du
patrimoine les visiteurs se sont brûlés
à versailles et à saint-quentin focus
son potager du roi et le fort de saint
cyr nous nous sommes rendu ce week-end
et un mot de religion tout d'abord la
fête de l'aïd el kébir fête du sacrifice
se déroulera ce jeudi
elle marquera la fin du pèlerinage sur
les lieux saints de l'islam et permettra
de communes commémorer la soumission
d'abraham à son dieu afin de répondre à
la demande de la communauté musulmane un
abattoir mobile a une nouvelle fois
était installé à trappes
près de soixante dix moutons par heure
seront sacrifiés samedi matin le marché
au vif a permis aux croyants de choisir
leurs animaux et nouveauté cette année
la possibilité de réserver sa bête à
l'avance ya un site internet
les précisions au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude je savais que je
serai occupé pour récurer du monde et
dès que énorme pour venir le choisir
ensuite bon il se peut qu'on soit occupé
à rendez-vous autre chose donc j'ai
préféré vu que c'était une proposition
sur internet j'ai préféré le choisir sur
internet au max et voilà c'est un site
de confiance on a confiance avec ces
gens là
l'éleveur les organisateurs et nous
poursuivons avec de la politique l'appel
du 19 septembre a été largement entendu
ce samedi dans toute la france des
centaines de maires ont manifesté contre
la baisse des allocs des dotations de
l'état alloués aux collectivités locales
dans les yvelines un rassemblement a eu
lieu à poissy de nombreux élus
principalement de droite étaient
présents pour réclamer une révision du
calendrier des baisses de dotations les
municipalités souhaitent également plus
de souplesse concernant l'effort
financier qui leur est demandé
william el est patrick jacq des x men
l'état français a le devoir d'entendre
et d'écouter le maire de france qui lui
demandent unanimement un étalement de la
baisse de la dgf pour sauver nos
communes
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines d'élus à
avoir répondu présent ce samedi à poissy
à l'appel de la mobilisation de
l'association des maires de france
au coeur des revendications la baisse
des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités locales
l'association évoque un danger sans
précédent qui pourrait conduire à une
réduction ou même une disparition des
services publics les maires veulent
sensibiliser à la fois l'état et leurs
populations l'état pour dire il faut une
autre méthode la population pour dire
attention soit y aura des augmentations
d'impôts soins il y aura une baisse des
services
c'est la réalité qu'il faut partager ce
n'est pas qu'une affaire de relations
entre les maires l'état c'est la réalité
de la commune certains services vont
être redéployés vont baisser
on va essayer de faire mieux ou appareil
à égalité de dépenses voire à baisses de
dépenses mais si une fois ces économies
faites
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que la
hausse d'impôts nous serons obligés
d'augmenter les impôts cette décision de
l'état de réduire de 30% les fonds
alloués aux collectivités locales un
pacte nécessairement leur fonctionnement
sur la commune de poissy la dotation de
6 millions quatre cent mille euros en
2014 passera à 4 millions huit cent
mille euros en 2015 la ville de plaisir
quand à elle enregistre une baisse de 1
million d'euros
nous sommes dans une réflexion forte et
au nous verrons avec la population avec
effectivement les élus
pour voir comment nous allons avancer et
faire des véritables choix pas forcément
dans l'augmentation mais peut-être dans
des suppressions de certains services et
l'état qui nous y impose une pétition
lancée en ligne par l'association des
maires de france a déjà récolté plus de
trente six mille signatures
ces mesures impopulaires représenterait
d'ici à 2017
un manque à gagner de 15 8 milliards
d'euros pour les communes et en plateau
pour en parler avec nous de cette baisse
des dotations de l'état jean michel
fourgous bonsoir à vous feront vous êtes
je le rappelle le maire d'elancourt et
premier vice président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la première question cette manifestation
samedi à poissy ce rassemblement c'est
quand même une démonstration de force à
tram à trois mois des élections
régionales c'est un moyen pour vous
occuper le terrain il ya non non je ne
sais pas mais il y a trois mille
communes qui ne pourront peut-être pas
payer leurs salariés
la fin de l'année donc en france est
grave c'est la première fois ces inédits
l'année prochaine dans 2016 dire à un
tiers des communes qui seront en
situation aussi de gravité aussi plus
sur le plan financier c'est grave c'est
peut-être le problème grave
je ne sais pas le problème il est il et
que nous on perd
je crois 3 millions rien que sur cette
dotation donc en quelques années plus
d'aider des nouvelles normes comme par
exemple les rythmes scolaires est une
fumisterie de première on nous impose ça
ça nous coûte un million plus ça sert à
rien ça sable qu'est ce que c'est que
son ordi de simplifier la vie des
entreprises et des mairies qu'est ce que
ces nouvelles normes toujours qu on nous
rajoute bon donc donc là en plus à nous
en nous enlever plusieurs millions de
dotations même chose à la casse qui la
situation est très grave
justement j'aimerais juste revenir sur
votre commune c'est de cette baisse des
dotations
comment ça se manifeste concrètement
pour l'été secteur puissent comprendre
vraiment les problèmes que vous avez à
gérer justement que votre commune
rencontre vise à éviter une baisse des
dotations à écouter sur sur trois ans je
crois qu'on perd ring ce soit les
notations 3 millions et en plus on a eu
les rythmes scolaires qui coûte entre
c'est ça varie entre 500 mille et un
million d'euros plus les augmentations
obligatoires plus on est dans une
situation où il ya un effet ciseau
commandes effet ciseau entre les
obligatoires les baisses de dotations
vous en effet ciseau sur une année de
près de 3 millions jours c'est très
grave il faut bien vous dire que je
crois que le conseil général ou
départementales du nord vient d'annoncer
qu'il ne pourrait pas payer le rsa ce
qui est la principale dépense d'un
conseil départemental à partir du 1er
octobre
il ya d'autres conseils départementaux
qui sont dans cette situation enfin
c'est très grave ce qui sera non plus le
problème c'est pas la chute des
dotations mais la chute de ce n'est
qu'un effet au delà vous avez en eau en
fait une équipe gouvernementale qui ne
s'est pas produit sur le problème des
régionales
et ne c'est moyen mais je vois pas trop
ce craquage salle hurle le password
programme riche soit ya pas un seul chef
d'entreprise dans le gouvernement
les tic sont en train de casser la
croissance sur l'année dernier en 2014
dernier bilan de l'année de croissants
on a zéro tout le président hollande
avait promis 2%
il fait 0 2 en 2014 7 à 10 % de
l'objectif pour maintenir la france en
équilibre forcément les effets les
effets c'est de la destruction de
recettes sociales et fiscales pour
l'état pour les collectivités et pour
les associations dont il faut bien
comprendre les faits d'abord c'est si
vous casser la croissance va vous casser
les recettes de l'is version
d'évaluation
la commune d'el en cours comment faites
vous justement vous par rapport à cette
baisse des dotations
comment faites vous pour votre budget
pour faire des économies justement ben
on ne renouvelle pas les départs on
allait chez les effectifs ont réduit
l'état dépense mais notamment en termes
qui faisait la qualité du service sont
réduits des services et surtout est le
plus grave c'est que
on a retiré deux investissements
importants 1 5 million sur un gymnase un
hôte de 5 millions aussi sur la colline
d'elancourt ce qu'était un projet de 50
millions tout ça ça tombe donc ont fait
chuter les investissements on est obligé
est donc ce qui fait chuter des
entreprises c'est grave dans le
département des yvelines
l'année dernière il y à une augmentation
de 40 % des dépôts de bilan c'est très
grave la situation restait par exemple
par rapport à la hausse des impôts
c'est quelque chose qui nous préoccupe
vous allez peut-être coûté on sera
certainement faut pas faire de promesses
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vous savez moi je
ne jouais les promesses de monsieur
hollande je veux dire je me dis qu'il
faut s'interdire de prononcer ce mot là
maintenant c'est dramatique
je pense qu'on s'intéresse dernier a
simplement on verra mais mais la
situation s'est fait ailleurs baissé de
5 soit vous bercer les qualités des
émissions supprimées ce vous sur vous
supprimez des postes de toute façon soit
vous faites baisser les investissements
enfin ce sont que des informations
négatives tout ça c'est à dire pourquoi
caston si tu devrais une véritable casse
du service public français aujourd'hui
c'est un peu justement c'est une vraie
préoccupation par rapport aux habitants
aux citoyens nous vous avons justement
de son année dans la commune de maurepas
et nous avons demandé à ses habitants
s'il craignait justement cette
augmentation je vous propose de regarder
ce micro trottoir un petit problème
technique nous verrons justement ce
micro trottoir dans quelques quelques
secondes pour en revenir à saint quentin
en yvelines
vous êtes également vice premier
vice-président de l'agglomération là
aussi on va faire des économies c'est
d'ailleurs mon père gardez faut
mobiliser plus de 10 millions mais bien
sûr il ya des tas de projets exemple ne
serait-ce que d'abord il est
malheureusement ceux qui ceux qui
subissent le ce malheur ce sont les
associations parce que je vous dis ça
tape le budget de l'état des
collectivités et des associations
donc faut bien voir que tout le monde
est concerné alors bien sûr on garde
les choses les plus les compétences les
plus obligatoire les plus les plus
importantes mais il ya des secteurs
comme la culture qui sont directement
touchés enfin je crois que l'année on
est en france on à annuler plus d'une
centaine de spectacles culturels donc
c'est grave ce qui se passe à saint
girons peu si on veut plus soutenir la
culture important la culture le sport ou
se fait tout tout tout le bien sûr les
départs de collaborateurs
c'est c'est inédit cette situation
d'abaissement du service public en
france et inédite tout ça parce que il
ya des gens qui ne voulaient le pouvoir
qui ne savent pas fan des richesses ils
sont cinq et de faire partie des
entreprises faire lever les capitaux
faire porter les talents bah oui quoi y
ait plus de production de richesses et
ben il ya moins de distribution et
justement on vous parlait à l'instant
des impôts on parlait il ya quelques
minutes le micro trottoir est maintenant
disponible je propose de le regarder
nous avons demandé à des habitants noirs
pacifique rennais justement cette hausse
des impôts
regardez bien sûr monsieur c'est tout à
fait normal parce que c'est pas
extensible et automatiquement mon en
subira les conséquences
il faut bien que les communes autres
aient de l'argent donc s'ils ont moins
de chez demandes seront ils vont
augmenter les impôts
chez c'est un plus mais non je crains
pas une augmentation des drapeaux par
contre je pense que c'est une
diminution des investissements si une
baisse des dotations d'état forcément
l'investissement risque de diminuer oui
forcément on craint toujours une
augmentation d'impôts dans ces cas là
mais malgré tout je pense qu'il faut que
tout le monde fasse des efforts quand il
ya plus d'argent rien appris voilà donc
je me fous il faut quand même faire des
économies avec le problème qui est
actuellement au gouvernement sont comme
des techniques sont nécessaires que
proposez-vous et est ce que si la droite
repasse au pouvoir en 2017 il faudra
revenir sur ses décisions selon vous il
faudrait surtout arrêter de taper sur
les gens qui investissent qui
entreprennent qui travaillent non c'est
pas ça dissipe pas donc il faudra
recréer un climat de confiance pour que
les gens réinvestissent parce que c'est
c'est c'est quand on enlève comment j'en
ai deux investissements et l'encours
s'est moins de travail d'entreprise il y
en a peut-être qui vont tomber assez
grave on va créer moins d'emplois où il
y aura moins de recettes sociales
fiscales donc il faut ça passe par
l'entreprise
il faut recréer un climat de confiance
il faut simplifier la vie des
entreprises c'est ce qu'ont fait dernier
avec la question n'est beaucoup de
projets pour simplifier la vie des
entreprises
c'est eux c'est la poule aux oeufs d'or
c'est la première était de ceux là les
textes et par mois le maire c'est c'est
l'entreprise qui me donne de l'argent
que je redistribue moi je ne suis qu'un
rang distribué en amande on conclura ce
qu'il fera revenir sur ces baisses de
dotations il faudra il faudra revenir
sur sur beaucoup de sueur beaucoup de
choses sur l'organisation sur
l'organisation par exemple certainement
du service public
bien sûr c'est très difficile vous savez
c'est dans ces dangereux pendant 18 mois
je sais plus complète deux ans il ya
beaucoup de discussions entre eux entre
les politiques là dessus
mais mais en tout cas si on avait une
croissance de 3% comme les anglais on
aurait pas de chute de nos dotations
faut que les français comprennent bien
que qu'ils apprennent les français aussi
qu' il n'y a pas de redistribution sans
production de richesses et le fait
qu'ils auraient peut-être dû comprendre
un jour il fallait pas taper comme ça
sur les producteurs de richesses on n'a
que les faits d'avoir tapé et ce ferry
enfin on arrive à se faire élire en
tapant sur les producteurs de richesses
et après on se demande pourquoi on est
tous dans la mouise devoir bien sûr là
la redistribution des choses qui bien
sûr diminué nous verrons donc les
résultats aux prochaines élections
régionales nous suivrons à ce dossier
avec attention merci jean michel récente
d'un colisée qui veut dire quelque chose
à voir
nous nous le verrons c'est ce qu'une
seconde malgré tout si je le pense merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et dans un
instant nous avons parlé d' alzheimer
car c'est aujourd'hui la journée
mondiale contre la maladie d'alzheimer
en france 900 mille personnes souffrent
de cette maladie il ya 225 mille
nouveaux cas chaque année plus de deux
millions de malades sont prévus à
l'horizon 2020 je vous propose de
regarder ce clip réalisé par france
alzheimer juste avant de recevoir notre
invité alzheimer une maladie qui touche
déjà trois millions de français et 25
nouvelles personnes toutes les aires
nous aider nos parents nos enfants nous
sommes tous concernés
alors
alors nous devons tous agir maintenant
on est dans les personnes malades leurs
familles
de la recherche et en soutenant
l'association france alzheimer et
maladies apparentées
et nous accueillons jacques si
jacqueline lalouette avec nous en
plateau jacqueline huet bonsoir merci
d'être venus vous êtes responsable de
l'antenne de 50 ans de france alzheimer
alors pour cette 19ème édition
l'association a choisi le thème prévenir
et aider pour mieux vivre la maladie
tout à fait vous pouvez m'en dire un
petit peu plus et notamment un message
pour les aidants tout à fait alors les
aidants ont besoin d'être aidés compris
soutenu parce que sinon ils vont l
épuisement l'aidant principal est
souvent le conjoint mais il est aussi
l'enfant qui travaillent ascendants
descendants ça fait beaucoup apporté et
il faut les aider et pour de temps en
temps allégé le fardeau on peut penser
aussi à des séries placement temporaire
accueil de jour je pense que tout ça ce
sont des mots qui sont maintenant
utilisées couramment et qui ont un sens
pour les familles en tout cas nous ne
développons ce sens lors des groupes de
paroles et des formations alors
justement j'aimerais qu'on revient sur
les actions que vous proposez costa
style ce sont des gens qui sont
générateurs en souffrance qui sont
confrontées à cette maladie qui viennent
vous voir quels conseils leur
donnez-vous rouve les aiguilles et
qu'est ce qui se passe un petit peu pour
tout à fait tout à fait alors nous
faisons de lait coule tu nous les
recevons est aussi nous faisons de la
formation pour les aidants familiaux de
façon à ce qu'il anticipait qu'ils
connaissent quelles sont les étapes
qu'ils rencontreront ensuite là il y a
cinq journées cinq demi journées par don
de trois heures donc c'était quand même
un processus long dont pour une
construction et savoir vers où on va
avec l'aide de la caisse nationale de
solidarité
une psychologue et moi même donc ce
groupe peut permettre d'avancer en
connaissance de cause et ensuite on leur
donne éventuellement une orientation
vers un groupe de parole dans ce groupe
de parole il y à un petit groupe de
10 une dizaine de personnes 6 8/10 pas
plus pour que ce soit très conviviale et
personnalisée de façon à ce que ces
familles soient accompagnés et que ses
difficultés soit un petit peu estompée
quelles sont les prochaines votations ou
est ce qu'on peut vous rencontrer dans
les jours peut-être à venir si on est
confronté justement à cette night day
mais voilà alors nous avons la chance
d'avoir des locaux ali ps qui est 3
place de la mairie à trappes
c'est un bâtiment qui accueille les
professionnels de la santé et les
associations
nous avons également des points
ressources dans différents endroits de
la ville nouvelle par exemple à cosma
guyancourt à malraux à montigny
également agir handicap voilà donc il ya
différents endroits pour nous rencontrer
je pense que dans toutes les
municipalités notre nos coordonnées sont
dans les petits bouquins remis en début
d'année quels conseils donneriez-vous à
la une personne qui a un dans son
entourage
voilà un un proche qui est confronté à
cette maladie
les premières étapes les premiers
réflexes date à avoir quand justement on
est à vous monter à cette situation
alors surtout un diagnostic précoce qui
permet d'un accompagnement de qualité de
façon à ce que le malade se sentent
compris compris et dès que la famille
n'aille pas à l'épuisement et qu'on
puisse l'entourent et la guider et la
réorienter vers les professionnels
lorsque lorsqu'il c'est nécessaire nous
connaissons localement quels sont les
professionnels de la santé et je pense
que nous alors dans chaque département
il y à un responsable d'antenne qui va
justement être le tissu local de cet
événement à saint martin du lean comment
fait-on pour vous contacter voilà alors
il y à un numéro de téléphone 01 30 60
03 63
voilà il ya également un mail jacqueline
louette sfr.fr et il ya également le
siège social de notre association qui
est à versailles et où il ya une
secrétaire à mi temps qui peut aussi
prendre le relais parce que en tant que
bénévole de temps en temps
je m'absente et puis je crois que là
tout est structuré pour que nous nous
soyons entendus
voilà merci beaucoup jacqueline wade est
revenu sur son plateau et d'avoir
répondu à notre question de faire parler
de cette maladie d'alzheimer je le
rappelle si vous voulez vous même plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet
www.francealzheimer.org merci la semaine
de la mobilité continue en vue de la
coop 21 la poste des hauts-de-seine et
des yvelines ont organisé un rallye
d'éco-conduite un rallye pas comme les
autres car le but n'est pas d'arriver
premier mais de consommer le moins
possible de carburant
une cinquantaine de salariés et
partenaires ont participé à cette course
en faveur de la transition énergétique
reportage de fanny bourdon et vendredi
dernier 27 équipages se sont élancés de
la plate forme industrielle de bois
d'arcy pour le premier rallye
d'éco-conduite de l'ouest francilien le
but rallier la plateforme industrielle
de villeneuve la garenne en consommant
le moins possible de carburant et de
batteries une course de 40 km organisée
par la poste afin de sensibiliser leurs
salariés à l'éco conduite
la conduite économique et économiser un
maximum de carburant ou conduite légère
et souple pas trop axé là sur
l'accélérateur est passé vitesse entre
1500 et 2000 tours minute
tous les facteurs du département ont
reçu une formation à l'éco-conduite les
gestes clés ils sont enseignés pour
adopter une conduite plus économes
l'ensemble de nos salariés formés par
nos filiales mobigreen c'est donc c'est
une formation sur site avec la mise en
place d'un simulateur qui est fait des
rappels à la fois sur le code de la
route les environnements
auxquels ils peuvent être confrontés et
qui leur met en place des simulations de
consommation pour qu'ils puissent se
rendre compte comment on agit
concrètement sur la diminution de la
consommation que ce soit thermique ou
électrique une conduite douce qui
apporte de nombreux avantages
une diminution des coûts de carburant
une conduite plus apaisé mais surtout
une réduction de l'empreinte sur
l'environnement l'objectif de la poste
et de réduire de 15% leurs émissions de
co2 d'ici 2020 et nous continuons avec
la culture ce week-end vous avez
certainement plus profité des journées
du patrimoine pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir à l'héritage évinois du côté
de versailles le château a su ravir ses
visiteurs en leur dévoilant quelques
trésors comme le grand hémicycle du
congrès les espaces parlementaires mais
aussi le potager du roi un potager
classé monument historique en 1926 en
1926 par dont nous sommes allé le
visiter à vos côtés regardez fruits et
légumes rares mais aussi plantes
médicales et exotiques sont étendues sur
9 hectares au potager du roi à
versailles créé en 1678 sur la demande
de louis xiv ce site historique
et depuis sa création un lieu
d'expérimentation c'est devenu un
exemple un sur deux laboratoires d'essai
d'expérimentation de transmission de
autour de l'horticulture autour de la
production de fruits et légumes mais pas
que une des particularités de ce lieu
c'est d'avoir été en production de
fruits et légumes en production
horticole depuis le 17e siècle sens au
moment de discontinuité un espace dans
laquelle on essaye de de conserver des
de valoriser
le savoir-faire des jardiniers ouvert
d'avril à octobre au public
le potager du roi organiser des visites
particulières ce week-end pour les
journées du patrimoine
les journées européennes du patrimoine
ont toujours une thématique donnée
nationalement là c'est le patrimoine du
28e 21e siècle c'est le patrimoine à
venir et c'est dans ce sens là que moi
j'ai voulu nous avons voulu avec les
jardiniers mettre en avant
l'agroécologie la programmation est
riche et varié noter que les saveurs du
potager du roi se dérouleront le
week-end du 3 et 4 octobre
cette fête du goût et du jardinage est
l'occasion de découvrir les savoir-faire
des jardiniers
plus d'une centaine d'événements été
organisée justement ce week-end parmi
les nombreuses possibles il y avait
celle du fort de san siro où est
installée la médiathèque de la chute de
l'architecturé et du patrimoine
reportage de sephora namani et attraits
greg d'x men pouvoir entrer dans ce
bâtiment fait quatre mille cinq cents
mètres carrés dont 3000 mètres carrés
consacrés à la conservation ou de ces
photos et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a me
vendre ton plat c'est bien parce qu'on
est l'un des plus grands ensembles de
conservation de photos en europe avec 15
millions de négatifs et on estime à 4
millions le nombre de nos tirages
photographiques organisés dans le cadre
des journées du patrimoine la visite
présentait le cheminement d'une photo à
son arrivée sur le site et le fond très
diversifiée du fort de saint cyr
conditionné documenté restaurée et
numérisée pour être mise en ligne le
fond retrace toute l'histoire de la
photographie de 1840 à 1990 pour avoir
des fonds qui
qui vont du coup représenter des
monuments historiques et des oeuvres
d'art c'est un trio mais notre coeur de
métier mais aussi de par l'histoire de
services énormément de photographies sur
la première guerre mondiale
et puis des photographies d'auteur donc
des portraits de la photographie vite
plus d'artistique et et de la
photographie de cinéma aussi les
expéditions
en afrique on a dit
océanie plus de 3000 m² héberge ce fonds
composé de différentes donation de
photographe reconnu parmi elles le font
nadara qui en 1950 qui expose un siècle
de photos de la moitié du 19e à la
moitié du 20e siècle
on estime que ça en est entre 250000
plaques de verre donc ses négatifs qui
vont de tout petits formats c'est
important et qui représente toutes les
célébrités auquel on peut penser donc on
pense à un peu de lait rahman est à
kourou bert à victor hugo prochaines
acquisitions prévues par le fort de
saint cyr la donation du fonds de willy
ronis et nous retrouvons notre chronique
culturelle du lundi avec sephora la
magnifiant dans sa réforme en douceur
florane alors aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter l'oeuvre de léo cooper léo
cooper qui fait l'objet d'une exposition
à l'espace noir et aux clayes-sous-bois
jusqu'au 16 octobre
certaines illustrations lui de léo
cooper ont fait le tour du monde et
pourtant ce nom reste assez méconnue des
coupeurs c'est l'illustrateur des films
de charlie chaplin face à exactement
petit des allées où cooper rêvait de
devenir un célèbre affichiste à l'image
de paul colin qui était un illustrateur
l'un des plus influents du 20e siècle et
c'est à l'âge de 20 ans qui le rejoint
l'atelier du célèbre affichiste hervé
morvan qui le forme et enfin par la
suite son assistant et c'est à ce moment
là que les occupants peur est devenue la
fléche east des films de charlie chaplin
alors pour l'anecdote you cooper travail
donc comme assistant chez hervé morvan
est à l'origine c'est hervé morvan qu'on
demande un projet d'illustrations pour
la fiche du film les temps modernes de
chaplin qui allaient ressortir en salles
lité de de mettre en concurrence 3
affichiste ou chevronnés dont hervé
morvan mais celui ci déjà pris par
d'autres affiches vous diraient certains
ou un peu vexé d'être mis en concurrence
vous dirai d'autres envois son assistant
à sa place pour participer à la
compétition et c'est le projet de léo
cooper qui est retenu et qui en fera le
célèbre affichiste qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et vous avez eu la chance de
le rencontrer lors du vernissage de
l'exposition très fort tout à fait j'ai
cherché à savoir d'ocoee les s'inspirait
pour créer une affiche
alors on pourrait s'attendre à ce qu'il
cherche à représenter une scène
importante du film et pas du tout il
nous explique lui même comment il
procède dans le dictateur si vous avez
vu le vide
jarno il fait un petit coiffeur donc la
parade
il fait à la fois un buggy coiffeur et
effet aux îles le dictateur est là donc
ça m'a donné l'idée du charlot qui coupe
la mèche djabi une affiche c'est
l'immédiateté
l'idée de la mégère n'ai pas du tout
envie ils étaient surpris que cap les ai
acceptées il a compris qu'ils avaient
qui avait une idée l'affiché une affiche
ne doit pas forcément représenter le
pays et pour qu'une affiche soit réussie
pas question de couleur ni règle majeure
ou géométrie particulière c'est une
question d' évidence la fiche s'imprime
sur du papier mais elle doit s'imprimer
dans la mémoire
une affiche doit être surprenante
elle doit être simple doit s'imposer
comme une évidence
on doit y avoir que l'essentiel
c'est pourquoi j'ai inventé un mot
évident ciel pour la touche c'était dans
le but évident sienne il ya la vie il ya
la danse et il ya le ciel
la fiche de carnelle pour moi c'est une
tapie parce que justement elle est
évidente ul alors on a retenu dans
l'oeuvre de léo cooper ses illustrations
des films de charlie chaplin notamment
le dictateur la ruée vers l'or les
lumières de la ville ou encore le kid
mailhiot cooper c'est également la fiche
du film emmanuelle film scandaleux pour
l'époque qui lui a valu le premier prix
de la fiche au festival de cannes en
eh bien merci sephora les cooper est
toujours en activité nous on vous
retrouve mercredi à 10h30 pour un
nouveau numéro de kiosques et nous
restons sur la culture le patrimoine
avec le château de versailles les tags
antisémites de dirty corner l'offre
polémique d'anish kapoor exposés aux
jardins versailles ont été masqués
samedi soir après une décision de
justice
le juge a tranché et le dispositif de
sécurité a été renforcée autour de
l'oeuvre
à présent c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec le séduit
sport présentée par michael almy d'euros
pour ma part je vous retrouve demain en
direct à 18h pour un nouveau numéro du
journal je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée